تقنيه نتعامل فيها مع العقل البشري بطريقه
ذكيه تخافها في الحياه فاذا وجهها في
العاب الفيديو هذه هي احدث وصفه للعلاج من
الفوبيا
غريبه غريبه خلونا نفسرها نفسر هذا
الموضوع هذه الطريقه تعمل على تعريض
المريض الى الشيء الذي يخشاه في محاكاه
حاسوبيه غير حقيقيه تخادع العقل البشري
حتى يتلاشى هذا الخوف رويدا الرويدا في
الواقع الحقيقي
يضع المعالجه النفسي عشرات السيناريوهات
بحسب حالات كل مريض ما بين
رهاب المسرح او التحدث امام المجموعات
الكبيره او حتى فوبيا الطيران وغيرها
والعلاج على ما يبدو يحقق نجاحا ملحوظا في
بحث ساجري عام 2022 حقق العلاج النفسي
بالواقع الافتراضي معدل نجاح وصل الى
90% مع الاشخاص الذين يعانون من اضطراب ما
بعد الصدمه اليوم يعادل ومع تطورات تقنيه
يامل المعالجون ان تصل ايضا الى منازل
الناس وان تكون متاحه للجميع في المستقبل
على كل حال زميلتنا لميس ابراهيم كالعادات
ستطلعنا على بعض النصائح الصحيه للسيطره
على الفوبيا دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
ما بين الخوف من السباحه وحتى الهلع من
زياره طبيب الاسنان تتعدد الفوبيات
والمصابون بالملايين حول العالم اخترنا
بعض النصائح للسيطره على الفوبيا من موقع
nhsn4 بشكل عام تجنب المخاوف او تجنب
المخاوف يجعلها اكثر صعوبه مهما كان الخوف
واجه وابدا في التلاشيق اذا شعرت مثلا
بالخوف من ركوب المصعد اليوم فمن الافضل
الصعود فيه غدا عندما يهاجمك القلق توقف
لحظه اغمض عينيك وتخيل مكانا ينعم بالامان
والهدوء كصوره لنفسك تمشي على شاطئ جميل
او ذكرى سعيده من الطفوله المشاعر
الايجابيه تمنح المزيد من الاسترخاء تحدث
عن المخاوف مع شريك او صديق او احد افراد
الاسره التقاسم هذه المخاوف مع المقربين
يضعف اهميتها في راسك ومن الضروري ايضا ان
تتحدث مع اختصاص اذا ساءت الامور اخيرا
امنح نفسك مكافاه عندما تنجح في تحدي
مخاوفك اذا نجحت في تعلم القياده مثلا او
استطعت التحدث امام العامه بحريه يمكنك
شراء كتاب او تناول وجبه شهيه
او حجز رحله لوجهه جديده
[موسيقى]
طبعا اتفضل يا عادل انا كنت بدي اسال عادل
قبل ما نبلش مع دكتوره اذا عنده فوبيز
وكان عم بيخبرني عنده فوبيا من الموت قال
لي ومن المستقبل
كيف بدك تتخلص من هدول الفوبيا ربما ربما
فوبيا الموت هو ان تفقدي عزيزا فبالتالي
ربما هذه واجهتها
استطعت مواجهتها ربما قليلا هذا اللي ماني
قادر الاقي له حل صعب نعمل لك جيم او
مستقبل ما سالتنيش طيب انا من ايش
انا اناني اشي غريب من الافاعي افاعي
الافاعي مستحيل انا ما بقدرش اشوف افعى
حتى على
التلفزيون ما بقدر طيب على كل حال خلينا
نحكي مع الدكتور الدكتور رح تقول لنا من
عمان مشاهدينا دكتوره ضحى العولمه
اختصاصيه نفسيه
العوامله اهلا بك دكتوره ضحى معانا في
صباح العربيه دكتوره كيف ممكن زي ما
بقولوا او جيم ممكن يعني تعيشنا بنفس
الموقف ولكن يعني مش على ارض الواقع
تساعدنا على ارض الواقع انا مثلا اذا عندي
من الافاعي هل هذا فعلا ممكن اتخلص منه
اذا عملت لعبة جيم وكانه في حوالي افاعي
فممكن اتخلص من هالخوف بقفصه اعوذ بالله
صباح الفل
صباح الورد هو فعلا زي ما انت تفضلتي
بالاول انه هي طريقه علاج جدا ناجحه
بتعتمد على
او انه التعرض لهذا الشيء اللي انا بخوفني
بس المفروض انه يكون
gual يعني بشكل تدريجي يعني مش من الاول
انا شخص كثير بخاف افرجيه بعالم افتراضي
مليء بالافاعي يعني زيك انت فهو بكون
والحلو بالموضوع كمان انه بكون انا عندي
ردود الافعال والفيد باك بوقت حقيقي يعني
انا ممكن مثلا لما اعالج شخص عنده فوبيا
ويجي ياخذ جلسه معي ممكن انه عم بيحكي لي
هو عن شو بخاف وشو بحس بوقت ما يتعرض لهذا
الحافز او الاستن يولاي بس بالعالم
الافتراضي وبالجيمز هاي بالعكس انا بقدر
اخذ ردود الافعال واشوف هو شو عم بيشعر
بوقتها بوقت حقيقي دكتوره يعني هل
المحاكاه هنا تعتمد على المخاوف اذا ما
كانت ماديه يعني مثلا الخوف من السقوط اذا
هناك مرتفع الخوف من الافاعي من من الثقوب
كما تعاني اشواق ما ادري ليش
فوبيه الثقوب ام انه الاشياء اللي هي غير
موجوده المستقبل القادم الى اخر كيف
اتعامل وياها
صح مضبوط لما بيكون العامل اللي انا بخاف
منه شيء ملموس اكيد بكون اسهل علاجه عن
طريق العالم الافتراضي زي ما انت قلت
[موسيقى]
طيب دكتوره انا بقدر اعرض الشخص لاله يعني
اوكي طيب يعني ممكن الشخص يفكر او يحس
بانه هو يتخلص من هاي الفوبيا عن طريق
استخدام السيميليشن او الجيمز ولكن لما
يجي على ارض الواقع هل بنقدر نضمن بانه
فعلا هو تخلص منها مجرد ما انه واجهها في
ارض في في العالم الافتراضي
انه يكون انه يكون تدريجي زي ما حكيت
ويمكن لاول مره اذا بتعرض بشكل حقيقي
للموقف او مثلا كشخص بخاف من المرتفعات
ممكن انه يكون برفقه حدا يعني تكون برضه
انه مش بس عالم افتراضي انه بالحقيقه كمان
تكون يعني من ضمن التربيه والترييتمنت انه
احنا نعرضه لاشي حقيقي بس بكون تحت اشراف
اخصائي طيب هل هذا يعتمد على الفئه
العمريه اذا ما كانوا من الشباب هم اقرب
الى التواصل عبر يعني
العالم الافتراضي اذا ما كان اكبر بالعمر
يكون هناك صعوبه ذكر او انثى هل تختلف
المساله
لا لا ما بتوقع انا بصراحه ما جربتها للان
بس عملت
ما بتفرق يعني هلا بنعرف الشباب الصغار هم
اسهل انهم يجربوا هذه الاشياء لانهم هم
اكس بوز معرضين لالها بس لا ما بتخيل انه
اذا كان فئه عمريه معينه تكون يعني عائق
في في طريقه العلاج هاي
او انه ذكر او انثى بس على الاقل بلاش
اطفال صغار لانه ممكن يعني تزيد عندهم
الفوبيا لانهم اكيد بيقدروا يفصلوا من بين
الواقع والعالم الافتراضي شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتوره ضحى العوامله اختصاصيه نفسيه كانت
معنا من عمان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات